you are a conscientious objector I was
down during Vietnam what was that
process like I mean you would have seen
firsthand the complexity of humanity
right there
I actually it was surprisingly easy for
me oddly enough I know a lot of guys who
tried to get co status during Vietnam
and who were refused it you know you you
probably know some of them because many
of them became Canadian when they
welcomed them they were turned down yes
you know back then it was said that the
most draft boards and all the draft
words were local they would not give you
a CEO status if you objected to Vietnam
they would only give it to you if you
were complete pacifist and written
objected to all wars and I was not a
complete pacifist you know that big
question they would always ask you is
would you we do a fort in World War two
against the Nazis well yes I would have
fought in World War two against the
Nazis because but the Vietcong were not
the Nazis and I didn't think America at
any business in Vietnam and and so forth
so I was objecting that particular war
and everyone told me well you'll never
get the co status but oddly enough I did
get the co status and relatively easily
and I learned later my draft board was
so conservative that they felt money
wonder why the co status should have it
because then he'll be branded forever as
a yellow-bellied coward and a traitor
and he'll his life will be ruined and
that would be enough punishment for him
so thank God for that
so they ruined my life and there I am
but no so I and I did two years
alternate service when in Vista
volunteer working in legal assistance in
Chicago you know using my journalism
background that they mostly had me doing
public relations and publicizing the
cases they were taken but it was an
interesting experience I got to get to
see a lot of stuff and I still think the
Vietnam War was a terrible mistake for
America but I still would have fought
against the Nazis they work that kind of
political uh belief system into the work
into the work well I don't do it
deliberately I mean I'm not writing an
allegory like Tolkien who you know was
sometimes accused that Lord of the Rings
was an allegory of World War two
which he always reacted to angrily
because he didn't he didn't believe in
that and either either do I if I want to
write about world war two or about
Vietnam alright about World War two
about or about Vietnam nonetheless my
belief certainly permeate some of smaug
of Ice and Fire Game of Thrones part of
it being my belief about war and
violence war is so central to fantasy so
much of of high fantasy and yet it's
these bloodless Wars where the heroes
are killing unending armies of Orcs and
the heroes themselves are not themselves
ever being killed killing everybody all
the time I love the character and
they're dead it's true I'm am guilty of
killing people but you know I think if
you if you're going to write about the
war and violence then show the cost show
how ugly it is show show show both sides
of it there's also I mean and on the
other side which sometimes get me gets
me in trouble from the other side of
political spectrum is the glory of war
which we those of us who are opposed to
war and would rather not have war tend
to forget about or try to pretend it
doesn't exist but if you read the
ancient historical sources people are
always talking about the glory of war
the banners had stirred to heart the
banners in the wind and in medieval days
the night you know a Middle Ages
everybody everything was brown you know
the the clothes were brown the ground
was brown it was a brown centuries but
the Knights would come out in colors
they wouldn't only people rich enough to
afford dyed clothing and they'd be in
their blues and their Crimson's and
their yellows there must have seemed
glorious to the peasants who were coming
and and their metal suits and going into
combat but then after the battle was
finished it would be like severed limbs
and everywhere and pools of blood near
eerie descriptions of the Hastings
battlefield after the Battle of Hastings
were fought and yeah they literally were
like leg streams of blood and giant
pools of blood there's a lot of blood in
the human being and when you're fighting
with these sharp swords and hacking off
limbs and you know hacking people in the
middle of the head is not a bloodless
exercise it's going to come out and it's
going to come out
and I think if you're gonna write about
that period then you should reflect
honestly what it's about and capture
both sides of that that you know
whatever emotional stirring we feel when
we see the banner proudly flying in the
wind and we hear the bugles charge and
the drums are beating and the armies
surge forward but also the aftermath